first donald trump is not a paragon
of personal moral virtue but on the
other hand
um no no politician
in my lifetime in fact i would say of
the last
70 years uh has done a more important
job
of going after the deep state
so you mentioned something that's like
bouncing around a lot on on twitter over
the last couple of months that
that a certain set of conservatives
think that it really is to protect
virtue or or a certain sense of morality
uh something like that um what would you
say to those guys when they say well if
we don't protect
virtue now of course now that becomes an
amorphous term depending on how they see
virtue but if we don't
uh defend virtue or morality which they
usually tie
very close to religion that then
individual rights ultimately will be
trampled upon anyway that you sort of
need that as a precursor
yeah when when did government ever make
men moral
right um you need freedom to be moral
the the best inculcator in my view
of virtue and believe me there is no
greater
proponent of the importance and
necessity
of moral virtue in society than than
than myself i mean in my view you you
to have a free society you have to have
a nation of moral
men and women you cannot have a nation
made up of moral reprobates
that goes without saying so um i
i stan no man do you think we sometimes
need them
do you think we sometimes need some
morally corrupt people
so the i mean we've made it somehow 40
minutes without mentioning the t word
but in many ways trump to me is
something like that like this is
obviously no
great moral virtuous person but in many
ways
he was the hammer that we needed to sort
of shake up the system
to break a lot of bad things that had
been sort of calcified
um but but didn't do it out of
no one's looking i don't even think the
biggest maga supporter is looking at
trump thinking oh this is the greatest
moral man
on earth but in a weird way he was the
necessary tool
do you think that is that possible to
bridge that divide
well sure i mean i i do think it is just
a
it's a fact two facts that you've
mentioned first donald trump is not
a paragon of personal moral virtue
but on the other hand um no no
politician in my lifetime in fact i
would say
of the last 70 years uh
has done a more important job of going
after the deep state
the deep state is something i think that
is real uh
and and and the date the deep state also
includes the mainstream media
um and so uh trump has launched
uh a three and a half year uh
assault on on all of the certitudes
and platitudes of of the the deep state
and and i do think that's been an
extraordinarily
uh important um development in american
political life
so do you sort of separate that from
morality in a traditional sense or is
that a type of morality actually
well i mean it's it's a type of morality
if it's directed
at um breaking down
um tyrannical power right so
sure uh the defenders of freedom
uh and i'm not suggesting that trump is
necessarily a defender of freedom
because he's certainly passed
i think a lot of laws that
have been antithetical to to freedom but
in the sort of in the macro
picture he's done many things
reducing taxes massively cutting
regulations
but most importantly you know is it's
identity
i would say the single most important
thing that he has done is to i is
literally just simply to have identified
the deep state
right and then to be attacking it on a
daily basis which as i've said
includes the media that that has that
itself has been one might say a kind of
revolutionary act
yeah well it feels like we're kind of in
one right now
um so revolution since you're talking
about revolutionary acts that that's the
fourth one
that they found to be self-evident
that's probably the scariest one for
most people and
especially in a weird time like this uh
let's let's talk about that a little bit
sure so
i think the most important thing to
remember dave is that
america is a revolutionary nation
and what i mean by that is we were
founded by a revolution
um we were we created a new nation
de novo out of nothing on a
tabula rasa but
built into the principles of the
declaration is
the idea that whenever any form of
government
becomes destructive of those ends or
purposes which is the protection of
rights
the declaration says that the people
have the right
to alter or abolish that government
right and that truth and
it was meant to be a truth not a truth
specific to 1776
but a universal permanent truth so
it applied in 1840 it applied in 1940
and it will apply again in 2040.
america is a revolutionary nation
however it's also important to note that
in the declaration of independence the
first
word that appears after the fourth
self-evident truth the revolution truth
is the word prudent
and what that means the importance of
that is that
you know you you you can't have some
crazy guy
living out in the in the in the woods of
idaho
declaring war on the american government
right
revolutions are dangerous things and
america's revolutionary founders they
understood that it's a
dangerous thing and you can't you can't
try to overturn your government for as
the declaration says
light and transient causes right
so jefferson never would have said that
that with the passage of the stamp act
that would be appropriate
to overthrow the british government but
according to jefferson when you get
the sugar act in 1764 the stamp act in
1765
the declaratory act in 66 and then the
towns and acts
in 1767 the t act in 73
and then most importantly the coercive
and prohibited
prohibitory acts in 1774 and 75
jefferson says look there is there is
clearly self-evidently a design
and that's a word that you see in the
declaration and you see it in the
revolutionary literature
there is a design on the part of british
imperial officials
to enslave us to deny us our freedoms
and rights
so if if each of those laws had been
passed by the british government
separated by 50 years each
there probably would have been no cause
for revolution but when compacted
in a in an 11 or just really it was a
10-year period
jefferson john adams uh george
washington even said
oh oh look this these are not just
passing acts these are not mistakes on
the part of the british
parliament that or or george iii
we can clearly discern a pattern
and that pattern leads in one direction
and that direction is slavery
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell